Oh black cab exclusive let's do it DJ
complex it's Ready Set Radio rockie
fresh in the building let's try without
here point due to the scope so that some
IMG homie luck ok it's rack in the
building I'm ready for whatever my girl
got crabs machine trying to hit lecture
used to when to get the champ burger
while detectors nice rings on me while
humping Oakland Alexis working on the
Freestyle hot every verse I'm so clean
with it ain't even got a cursed friend
about my girl occurs I'm sipping on the
smart water oh do hate and i'ma give it
to a smart daughter I'm straight chillin
chillin like a villain got my mind on
the million finish stacking to the
ceiling straight off the top the homie
never flop I'm the Flies guy ever just
wait till I drop they gonna head and
then the album everybody asked about him
MMG betta teen all my homies little
dream forever stacking cream you know
what I mean yeah I'm straight spit and
telling mr. give me uh huh yo off the
top of the head shop shut about nah dawg
amen thank you for that I thanks for
really freestyle imagine yeah hey cuz we
he's like when I can't curse hey this
dude actually wrapped off the top of his
head a lot of rappers might want to take
note I right onto the team you gonna do
something like maybe you got written we
flip switch up the beat on you honestly
I'm gonna tell you something already
right that much oh you don't I just be
rapping I'm Sam I never saw another
betta up again don't another being
complices do one more time man its power
98.3 mess my first time on the radio
Arizona we gotta turn Ready Set Radio
rockie fresh in the building man MMG in
here at bootleg cab at rocky fresh at
diageo at the PHX at the Angelo high
lattice let's do it complex
you got some over their cupcakes hey
yeah huh mine is crazy let's go yeah
look okay see I was in supreme when they
was rockin my skin had bape on my scene
when they was Angie no green the flash
player ever forever I keep it clean MMG
be the team all of my homies gleaming
all of these whips is me I see why they
got hate for me as I be going hard and
they be bowing out gracefully you go see
with Cindy's a pcs and she catch a DD
add a number to my phone then you know I
take a home if people paid attention 8c
I never linked I got a nice balance I
can walk along the beam and I set the
bar high so I'm hoping they can pull
vote they sleeping on me count Amelia
why they chose up then I break my bro's
off you're my whole team eating we
blowing strong to the weekend and girls
we deepen it's our season like we own
the spice rack every time they think we
fall off you're coming right back it's
nothing i'm chilling out in the Arizona
I got the bad girls you know that i'll
be chillin on the ipass until my homies
if I'm even one I'm coming up the town
once again I tell them bring a friend
the only thing I know how to do its
rapid spin they call me up I'm standing
out then I got it in I'm coming off the
bench repping for the side town all the
real players by my tones when they ride
around I'm still flowing still going
cold like it's snowing my role go Rosie
rocking and they know I'm rolling I'm
not her strolling night they pans down
I'm bowling my chain frozen everybody
know it's open I don't know
[__] rat Wow Phoenix he just got
blessed right he just also taught me
yeah man